rising more than 2,000 metres above sea
level the sham showed is the highest
peak in the chateaus range visitors come
from all over the world to enjoy the
beauty of the region many stay at bruno
Charles's converted barn the village of
lisabean chateaus has a cultural trail
that begins at the 900 year old church
in this mountainous region perhaps the
remnants of the past are easier to see
because mountain people don't move
around as much they stay attached to
their identity and traditions and they
like to share them with visitors winter
sports enthusiasts seeking a less
strenuous holiday prefer the shed close
to even the Alps
and visitors to the National Park can
get an authentic taste of French country
life
this cultural trail leads curious
visitors through the countryside into
the past this grain Depot is more than
500 years old the construction is quite
special it's completely made of wood
with interlocking pieces of timber the
sort of construction is quite typical
for this region and alpine valleys the
local farms sell French regional
specialities
for example products made with saffron
this farmer is on hand to explain to
visitors how she produces her wares
a few kilometers further along a farm
shop is selling 15 different varieties
of homemade cheese tourism agriculture
and forestry are all vital for the
50,000 inhabitants of the chateaus the
regional government has implemented
strict nature protection laws to make
tourism as sustainable as possible while
maintaining the area's natural beauty
the mountains here are more gentle than
the central Alps or the plough region
you can see in the colours the shapes
and the lines because I was born here my
family and my ancestors were here before
me as I meet them is all set for the
most famous cultural heritage site in
shatru ziz well hidden in its mountains
the head Monastery of the confusion
order founded in 1080 for about fifty
thousand visitors are drawn here every
year but none are permitted to actually
visit the monastery the monks prefer
that their contemplation remain
undisturbed instead a nearby museum
tells their story the order has always
been very limited in size but its
philosophical and spiritual importance
for Christianity as a whole has been
enormous
throughout its history many famous
people such as jean-jacques Rousseau
have come to seek inspiration from the
everyday lives and the spirituality of
the people here the one today many
people still
to find out more about what goes on
behind these walls so kiss the bass
there yes they will the monastery walls
hold many secrets such as the 300 year
old recipe for this green liquor shadows
also lends its name to the mixture of a
hundred and thirty herbs plants and
flowers that go into the drink
the distillery in nearby waha is open to
the public so the model you click on
Plex it really is a very complex liquor
it's currently quite fashionable with
barman and cocktail mixers they know
lots of ways to use it they add other
Lee curves or fruit juices and they make
marvelous cocktails
maybe you cook thing at the end of each
tour visitors can taste a sample after
all it's often said that chateaus has
medicinal properties